ce matin à Paris les voyageurs de la
gare du Nord ont assisté à une scène
terrifiante une attaque alarme blanche
munie de son arme blanche un individu a
décidé de s'en prendre à des usagers au
total 6 personnes ont été blessées dans
cette attaque tandis que le mobile de
l'agresseur reste encore flou l'homme a
pu être rapidement arrêté par des
passants et par les forces de l'ordre il
a été neutralisé par les forces de
l'ordre qui elle-même ont fait usage de
leur arme une intervention rapide que le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
a tenu à souligner arriver sur place peu
de temps après le drame sans
l'intervention extrêmement rapide des
policiers il y aurait très certainement
eu des victimes et moi je voudrais
simplement les remercier attaque au
couteau à la gare du Nord que s'est-il
vraiment passé un policier nous dit tout
alors c'est con parce qu'il est parti
[Musique]
en direct
demain voilà est-ce qu'ils peuvent venir
demain
je regarde ça voilà et voilà parce que
comme ça bah ça ce sera fait merci en
tout cas merci à Reda que j'aime
beaucoup voilà secrétaire départemental
LGP police qui est un garçon
exceptionnel et là et je suis toujours
très content de le voir et qui adore son
métier et qui fait le max à chaque fois
donc merci d'être là mon Reda parce que
tu sais comme comme tu es haut dans mon
estime alors raconte-nous ce qui s'est
passé ce matin à la gare du Nord alors
déjà je voudrais féliciter l'ensemble
des effectifs qui sont intervenus aussi
avec une efficacité et puis ils ont fait
preuve d'un grand professionnalisme et
puis une pensée aussi pour les six
victimes donc policier et une victime
civile qui est actuellement qui a été
grèvement blessé donc ce matin vers 6h45
un individu au moyen d'un poinçon
artisanal à attaquer plusieurs personnes
au niveau du parvis de la gare du Nord
ensuite il y a des civils qui ont tenté
de s'interposer il est rentré dans la
gare du Nord au niveau du hall et là il
a agressé plusieurs autres personnes et
s'en suit des policiers de la police aux
frontière ont entendu des cris au niveau
du hall sont descendus très rapidement
et ont tenté de neutraliser l'individu
un collègue à saturé l'individu en
question et l'individu en a profité donc
du coup pour lui planter l'arme blanche
au niveau de la nuque et ensuite vous
avez un policier hors service et
d'autres collègues qui étaient avec le
collègue de la police aux frontière qui
ont fait usage de leur arme pour notre
raser neutraliser l'individu alors la
police intervenue en une minute une
minute 15 à peu près exactement voilà
donc c'est vrai que ça a évité un énorme
drame encore plus grave que c'est déjà
que c'est un drame et c'est vrai que vos
collègues ont été incroyables ils
étaient autorisés à tirer là ah oui on
était dans on était complètement dans le
cadre dans la légitime défense
sur leur intervention ça aurait été
bien pire ah oui oui si jamais pas eu
les policiers je pense qu'il y aurait
beaucoup beaucoup plus de victimes parce
qu'il y a un individu en moins de 2
minutes qui blesse 6 personnes
ou pas le l'enquête pour l'instant dit
que oui voilà et apparemment vous pouvez
pas le renvoyer en Libye oui mais
locuteur c'est un peu c'est technique
vous avez ce qu'on appelle loc qtf sèche
ou la personne est libre et elle doit
elle à l'obligation de quitter le
territoire et vous avez locuteur de
maintien dans un centre de rétention
administrative où là l'individu est
gardé sous notre responsabilité et dès
qu'on a un billet d'avion et qu'on a
identifié son vrai pays d'origine on
l'envoie sur la Libye il y a un petit
oui alors ça c'est plus politique mais
exactement pour les téléspectateurs
c'est important aussi pourquoi on peut
pas le voyant l'instabilité du pays
il y a une règle quand le pays d'origine
est instable on n'a pas le droit je vous
dis de envoyer
dans son pays donc quand même c'est
parce que c'est si j'ai fait beaucoup de
choses circuler cet après-midi et ça
c'est quand même important de le
signaler pour bien dire voilà que là
donc ce qu'on est en train de dire à
noter les spectateurs à 20h45 en direct
impossible de l'éviter oui c'est
difficile c'est impossible comment on
peut comment on peut un moment et c'est
vachement savoir qui va se passer ça il
faisait quoi dans la gare on sait pas
parce que vous savez que c'est la gare
du Nord gare du Nord c'est criminogène
quand même il y a beaucoup de
délinquance vous avez comme l'a dit vous
avez un le ressort donc vous avez
beaucoup de d'étrangers donc vous avez
des pickpockets vous avez des marginaux
beaucoup de marginaux qui nous dit
aujourd'hui que ces individus là étaient
pas marginal qui souhaitait souvent dans
la gare et c'est une problématique et
nous policiers en tout cas je suis
obligé d'en parler notre organisation se
bat beaucoup pour qu'on ait plus de
policiers sur cette gare et c'est
difficile aujourd'hui de parce qu'il
faut vouloir être policier aussi vouloir
aller travailler la gare du Nord c'est
pas tous les jours facile alors il a été
blessé forcément bien sûr dans un état
très très grave mais un moment comment
vous voulez faire c'est c'est compliqué
de
se faire autrement oui alors ce qui est
terrible chez cette personne c'est que
on va dire qu'il est instable donc on va
voir comment ça va se passer
psychologiquement déstabilisé ou est-ce
qu'on voudra mais il y a quand même eu
l'intelligence toute sa carrière
dirais-je de délinquant ici en France de
de changer d'identité plusieurs fois ça
c'était reconnu par la police et il
paraît qu'il a changé un coup il est
algérien un coup les marocain un coup il
est tunisien un coup et la réalité c'est
que justement et ça est-ce que ça est-ce
que c'est pas une curieux est-ce que
c'est pas une alerte c'est ce qui est
pas bon quelque chose qui fait qu'on
peut ça peut alerter les services de
police ben malheureusement
chez nous ça fonctionne comme ça faut
souvent qu'il y a un fait divers pour
que les choses j'espère que ça va le ça
va le faire il faudra peut-être beaucoup
plus d'effectifs sur la garde du Nord
renforcer les brigades de réseaux
franciliens renforcer la police aux
frontières et puis déjà on va résorber
cette problématique là parce que le fait
que si il y avait eu plus de policiers
sur les mêmes si c'était à 6h45 du matin
le gars il serait peut-être pas attaqué
comme ça à plusieurs à plusieurs
personnes il est pas connu pour ce type
de faire ma connaissance il est pas
connu pour ça sur je viens pour pour
expliquer notre spectateurs il y avait
pas de policiers sur le terrain à
première vue ils sont arrivés
après ou d'une minute ils étaient où les
policiers en fait ils étaient au dessus
au niveau de l'Eurostar pour les
policiers aux frontières et puis vous
aviez un collègue qui était un ou deux
collègues qui étaient hors service
alors oui son arme voilà on est obligé
de faire un tir régulier au moitié trois
tirs par an pour pouvoir garder notre
arme d'accord et donc ça c'est une
obligation donc ça c'est important mais
c'est vrai que bon on est censé on a sur
notre carte de police à l'arrière c'est
marqué toute personne doit laisser
passer ce fonctionnaire de police et oui
en effet on a le droit de garder notre
arbre
c'était aussi une chance qui est entre
guillemets qui ait des policiers mais
même les policiers en service l'enquête
le confirma mais même les policiers en
service de les policiers la police aux
frontières pardon on fait usage de leur
arme aussi bien sûr ça a pas été précisé
mais voilà donc ils étaient en service
ils ont utilisé pour moi je reviens à
l'agresseur ok il peut pas être expulsé
en Libye il y a pas de canaux d'échange
c'est très compliqué payer mais il a
quand même visiblement un profil
inquiétant multi-identité moi je ne
comprends pas que ces gens-là qui est un
oculaire pour le coup soit pas placé
dans un centre de rétention alors vous
allez me dire centre de rétention il y a
des limites c'est 90 jours mais là c'est
le profil type d'une personnalité qui
peut passer à l'action à tout moment et
ça moi ça me paraît des profils
extrêmement dangereux je suis désolé la
gare du Nord c'est la troisième gare
mondiale en termes de passagers on peut
pas laisser des gens comme ça non mais
il faut dire posterioriage
quand tu veux toi toi
non mais c'est vrai c'est incroyable ça
sécuritaire quand tu le veux il y a
quelqu'un qui peut rentrer chez toi et
tu dis bah tu vas lui dire non merci
Monsieur il faut pas rentrer et là et là
tu es sécurité là là là je vais te dire
et je le dis franchement et je dis pas
ça pour défendre mon pote qui est là et
qu'il d'ailleurs la police on a rien à
le reprocher une minute pour arriver
comment tu veux mais comment tu veux
savoir mais c'est impossible lâche-le
c'est impossible ça sera arrivé dans
tous les pays du monde ne crois pas même
les pays les plus sécuritaires ce sera
arrivé c'est impossible tu as toutes les
on le voit bien et oui la vérité je dis
une connerie quand on dit ça ou pas
cette pâte
je suis d'accord avec vous mais je peux
dire après ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'au niveau de de ces services là le
service parisien on a de moins en moins
d'effectif et ça c'est une réalité le
jour vous aurez beaucoup plus de
policiers donc non mais dis-le parce que
peut-être que Gilles a raison alors tu
dis s'il y avait plus de policiers ce
serait pas arrivé je dis pas que ce
serait pas arrivé mais
la gare du Nord il a quand même une
armateur artisanale donc on va pas dire
qu'il a prémédité mais il est quand même
armé sachant qu'il y a des policiers
beaucoup de policiers sur les lieux ça
vient quand même de la délinquance sur
un truc ce que vient de dire Gilles sur
un truc sur la gare du Nord on sait que
c'est extrêmement dangereux parce que il
y a pas moyen de renforcer les effectifs
bah nous en tout cas c'est une
revendication et alors et c'est
compliqué c'est vrai que les gilets
jaunes à beaucoup renforcé certains
services et d'autres on les de ce côté
de ça non je veux pas parler de la
banlieue parce que c'est encore c'est
encore pire mais aujourd'hui
d'intervention c'est pas mal oui mais
oui mais si comme il a dit s'il y avait
des policiers dans la gare du Nord côté
moi bien c'est un coupe-gorge mentir à
6h du matin c'est un coupe-gorge voilà
donc je te dis donc forcément euh des
horaires c'est un peu plus compliqué la
nuit jusqu'à même voilà même jusqu'à 14
15h
on peut pas prévoir ce genre de choses
alors non mais ça je suis d'accord avec
toi c'est ce que je viens de dire je
suis d'accord avec toi et sur un truc ce
qu'il dit c'est que c'est dissuadifs si
tu avais plus de services de police mine
de rien voilà vous avez un petit peu
tous les deux raisons que ce soit Gilles
et toi mais même si c'est vrai qu'on
peut pas prévoir à un moment la gare du
Nord on sait que c'est quand même c'est
compliqué normalement oui mais bon
mais quand vous dites qu'on peut pas
prévoir le l'homme a une occupé il
devrait pas être sur le territoire
comment on peut accepter qu'il y ait des
gens des des je sais même pas combien
ils sont sur le territoire des gens qui
n'ont pas qui ne peuvent pas être
finalement sur le territoire
bilatéraux
c'est une fatalité on accepte et on
prend ses risques là tous les jours et
on en parle comme ça tranquille
qui m'envoie des infos si besoin voilà
pour récapituler un peu l'affaire et les
infos qu'on a donc identité réelle non
connu pour l'instant c'est pas vraiment
voilà ces empreintes passées au fichier
montre dans le passé quand il a eu
affaire à la police il a déclaré
différents d'identité c'est ce que vous
disiez parfois il s'est dit algérien
parfois lit bien sans que des documents
viennent la tester ça là dessus l'agile
là excuse-moi j'étais un peu virulent
mais au fil c'est vrai que tu as raison
parce que le profil quand même un trou
blanc sous ces 10 identités à légué il
faut l'objet de deux occultes TF un vers
la Libye notamment dater de l'été
dernier donc faire partir à l'été
dernier en Libye côté justice il a déjà
été condamné par la justice française
deux fois une amende pour violation de
propriété 4 mois avec sursis pour vol il
est encore à l'hôpital il n'a pas encore
pu être entendu par les enquêteurs et
ses motivations restent inconnues pour
le moment voilà donc avoir affaire deux
fois la justice effectivement il y a
quand même dehors malgré le PTF c'est
vrai que ça paraît quand même un tout
petit peu laxiste merci en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous encore bravo
service de police bravo mon réveil
[Applaudissements]